hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday my 60 2020 what's going on
how are you
is this up to loud here maybe a little
bit let's turn it down a little bit
there we go I don't want to have the
volume up at up huh
there's a segue speaking of segues how
dumb to all the people feel who blew all
their money on a [ __ ] Segway instead
of [ __ ] on some bread and milk is all
these [ __ ] people lose their minds
jesus [ __ ] christ I I swear to god
man I swear to God I watching people's
behavior since the last podcast the run
on food at grocery stores the absolute
ridiculous level of food that people
bought most of which will go bad within
a [ __ ] week you [ __ ] over your
fellow man I actually that there was a
sense of freedom to it I have to admit
you know all of these [ __ ] goddamn
liberal [ __ ] that live out here and I'm
liberal too all right
I'm liberal too just like I'm a [ __ ]
sports fan but I'm not above saying my
team got a call they shouldn't have got
all right that's the kind of liberal I
am if you got a problem with that then
why don't you just take out your [ __ ]
anyway all these [ __ ] liberal [ __ ]
[ __ ] out here going on award shows
telling everybody how they should be and
how to be a better person you saw who
the [ __ ] they really are when the [ __ ]
didn't even hit the fan there was just
an odor of [ __ ] in the air right these
[ __ ] people all of their [ __ ] you
know this is a safe space this is a
place of increases inclusive you need to
be canceled and I like the way you talk
to bla bla bla bla blue all of that went
out the [ __ ] window it went from
[ __ ] progressive
you know do you boo - [ __ ] you [ __ ] him
[ __ ] her [ __ ] they I am buying up all
the butter and eggs and bread that I can
[ __ ] carry [ __ ] hilarious and I'm
not I'm not just coming down on the blue
tide people the red Thai people - all
right all you support the troops America
love it or leave it
none of you are Americans who did that
none of you are Americans
you're individuals you're Americans when
it's it's good to be a [ __ ] American
but at the end of the day when just the
width of air whiff of [ __ ] was in the
air you [ __ ] [ __ ] yourself in the
[ __ ] foxhole you were that guy when
the plane [ __ ] crashed and you're
sitting in the [ __ ] Himalayas and
you're waiting for the rescue group you
were the one who took more than you
share anyways this is the Monday morning
podcast and that was so goddamn funny
watching everybody going out of the
[ __ ] grocery store I did not kind of
regretting that right now considering
what was left when I finally got down
there but I didn't stand in line I went
down to my butcher the only thing left
was like a [ __ ] brontosaurus side
slab of [ __ ] corn beef so do you want
to celebrate st. Patrick's Day for the
next three months I got the [ __ ] slab
of it so I guess I don't know I don't
know what to do with that but it just it
just blew my my was sitting there was
scratching my bald head going all right
if you're really afraid of this virus
that is affected less than 1% of the
people in this country all right not
saying they doing the wrong thing
because they are doing the right thing
okay why the [ __ ] would you go down to a
grocery store with 300 400 other [ __ ]
people all breathing all over your food
touching your [ __ ] food in close
quarters with all of them why wouldn't
you just post me some food and roll the
dice with one [ __ ] stranger you know
come to the door with your little
spritzer
have them set the bag down how are you
god bless america spritz the [ __ ]
handles on the bag
and that's it they lost their [ __ ]
minds
here's the deal man all right I think
the government is doing an unbelievably
great job at handling this whole [ __ ]
thing okay and I think this is one of
the few times where I am I am Pro
Authority you just do what they say and
everybody pulls in the same direction
and then this thing will be over but
what the [ __ ] problem is okay is
there's too many mouths breathe and
[ __ ] morons
there's too many panicked people and
then there's too many people living in
their ego the ego people of my favorites
you know what I mean it's like every
time there's a hurricane there's always
that handful of douchebags who have to
go out and go surfing and then they get
themselves in trouble and then these
[ __ ] responsible citizens at the
Coast Guard now have to risk their life
in ever seeing their loved ones again to
get you a dumb ass out of the [ __ ]
ocean you know all of these young kids
doing what I would have done if I was
young not judging but all of them going
out to bars and day you know Yolo that's
one of my favorite [ __ ] internet
expressions ever especially when it's
self awarded you know I give no [ __ ]
first of all if that was true you
wouldn't you wouldn't be wasting time
announcing that to other people because
you give no [ __ ] but you actually give
a [ __ ] enough to announce to people that
you give no [ __ ] so you don't give a
[ __ ] everybody gives a [ __ ] all right
those people you see out at bars are
young and nothing bad at that level has
happened to him nothing bad at that
level has happened to me all right but
you know I got a I've had enough frozen
shoulders in my life I pulled enough
hamstrings to realize I'm not special
those young kids they got brand-new
bodies all right they're they're out
there [ __ ] they're not even using
condoms and plus I actually think that
it's a conspiracy by young people if you
if you if
you have your finger on the pulse of the
zeitgeist if I'm using that word
correctly of social media there's been a
lot of back and forth between baby
boomers and anybody under the age of 35
which boomers all consider to be
Millennials when the reality is a lot of
baby boomers again I always like I mean
Millennials are like 1980 to 1995 so
they're actually turning 40 all the way
down to like 25 years old so they call
all college kids all them that
Generation Z or Y whatever the [ __ ] they
are I don't I don't even [ __ ] know I
don't give a [ __ ] either but I think
they're like hey man I think we can ride
this [ __ ] out
but these older people can't so they're
gonna do like a generational Menendez
thing remember the Menendez brothers
minin and Mendez
so they say the name minute and then man
then and then des they [ __ ] killed
their [ __ ] parents and then they said
they got touched funny by the dead so
they blew both their parents heads off
that's the C nc-17 version of the Sesame
Street song Mahna Mahna anyway yeah I
think that they're trying to kill the
older generation all right which is
funny because that's what the baby
boomers tried to do right you remember
[ __ ] Jim Morrison they got the power
we got the numbers I think that's why he
got killed I think they killed him
because he sang that song and the
[ __ ] greatest generation there's
other people they were all over came
before the great the Silent Generation
they all got yeah they killed him
silently you know but it being a great
thing for his [ __ ] legacy because
I've always maintained that if Jim
Morrison had actually lived he probably
be bald you know had a really bad
hairpiece
you know with this long stringy [ __ ]
tumbleweed hair at that point playing
casinos you know walking up to chicks in
the [ __ ] Generation Z whatever the
[ __ ] they are just being like hey man
the Lizard King right that was me
I said that [ __ ] I'm the guy who said we
can't get no higher on the Ed Sullivan
Show I'm a rebel right I mean ever like
fake [ __ ] hips and [ __ ] and these
from all the drugs he did it's probably
a good thing what am I talking about I
don't [ __ ] know anyway but this is a
great opportunity everybody to practice
being in a panic situation and
maintaining your cool you know I think
we should all just be nice to each other
I don't think you should buy all [ __ ]
58 things of milk because they're there
and [ __ ] everybody else I don't think
you need to go Ted Nugent on this one
I'll psyche the role of those people by
the way shout out to Ted Nugent and all
of those other people who for years have
been laughed at by the people who live
in cities the people on award shows they
called them flyover States and all of
that [ __ ] Ted Nugent has enough [ __ ]
bear meat in one of his 58 freezers in
his panic room to [ __ ] save an entire
state all of those people god bless them
all of those people that will all the
Doomsday Preppers everybody that they
saw this day coming right and then
everybody gets mad at them it makes fun
of them because they don't like to
because you know what it is in the back
of their heads I think that they knew
who they were that as much as they were
out there going you know we need to be
inclusive and you know used the right
terms or I'm gonna cancel you this is a
safe space they all knew in the back of
their heads that when the [ __ ] hit the
fan they knew what they were doing they
were going down to the supermarket and
they were gonna buy all the [ __ ] food
they could possibly carry and [ __ ]
everybody else that's what they were
gonna they knew that's why they what's
why they would campaign it so hard it's
like that joke I did in my special right
about the [ __ ] male feminist any guy
that said you know I'm a [ __ ] male
feminist had like the dead hooker under
his did he did something alright
anyway I don't want [ __ ] I'm talking
about here so let's get back to this
[ __ ] so I can tell you this the
government is doing a [ __ ] amazing
job around the world the government's
are doing an amazing job with this and
they actually have your best interest
okay not because they care about you but
like I said before if you're dead they
can no longer exploit you okay and then
they would have to [ __ ] start digging
[ __ ] up out of a ground out of the
ground and [ __ ] putting [ __ ] together
they don't want to do that they want you
to be alive so you can continue to do
the jobs they need you to do okay I'm
actually making rich people into a
cartoon right I mean you know when you
do run [ __ ] you work seven days a week
that I'm but believe it or not that's
how it is you don't sit around smoking
cigars laughing your asses off ass off
you don't you know because then you make
a bunch of money and everybody tries to
take it away from you
it's basically it's just you can never
let your guard down I think that that's
what it is so you know I do a podcast
network all things comedy network and I
can tell you just trying to run that
thing and get everybody to pull in the
same direction in a direction that we
feel is beneficial for all is a very
difficult thing to do and I'm not even
saying that up well I'm always saying
what the direction of pulling is right
but I'm just saying it's very difficult
forget about trying to tell an entire
country of people to just stay home and
[ __ ] chill out and the amount of
people that they I talked to some of my
friends like - yeah I wouldn't give a
[ __ ] if they told me not to go to
college I hated school dude I would be
sitting at home with all of my friends
playing cards and drinking booze like
you [ __ ] read about and it just crack
me up it's like then you just negated
the whole [ __ ] reason why they sent
you home but people they get into this
whole [ __ ] thing of like yeah I don't
give a [ __ ] and I'm not just saying it's
young people I know a couple older
people older meaning older than me and
you know these news junkies on the right
are trying to say that this entire
[ __ ] thing is a conspiracy theory as
a conspiracy to take
down [ __ ] Donald Trump I mean how
[ __ ] funny is that I mean this thing
is hurting everybody I don't know I I
don't understand well actually I do I
kind of got out of you know it's funny
is I got out of all that doomsday
prepping [ __ ] I just got tired of living
in that heightened state of what-if and
so I was I was not prepared at all but I
can fly that helicopter I don't know
somebody actually sent me a picture of
this giant helicopter said you know
let's load this thing up bill do you
know how to fly this thing it's like
look if you can see if you can figure
out how to start it up I can fly it I'm
not gonna say I can land it I can get
that thing up in the [ __ ] air and I
can keep it straight and level and I can
make those [ __ ] radio calls but we
might be looking at the the [ __ ] what
do you call that the what did the [ __ ]
you call that book that comes with every
[ __ ] helicopter show Jonah started up
the operation manual that was always
great about Rambo he knew how to fly and
[ __ ] drive everything he didn't need
to figure it out the man knew every form
of transportation get that guy in a
[ __ ] locomotive he would have got
that thing going anyway plowing ahead
here yeah so I don't know I'm just
chilling here at home I gotta be honest
with you I mean I am [ __ ] bored out
of my mind I have been begging for
[ __ ] two weeks off a month off for
[ __ ] 28 years being in this business
you know when I first started out I
obviously still had a day job so I had
my day job and then at night I did
stand-up and I don't know ever since
then I've just been working and I
finally have the time off this isn't
this wasn't how I wanted it to be I'll
tell you another thing I don't have any
cigars and I was just thinking you know
if this thing is gonna [ __ ] kill
everybody
right this is the time to smoke up
and I have nothing by the way I have not
smoked since I smoked with virzi so I've
smoked one time in like I don't know I
don't even know how long it's been I
don't even know I'm not even counting
[ __ ] days it said some in the 60s so
I have conquered that habit I am now on
an amazing diet that was going great and
then I went down to the [ __ ]
supermarket and everything I needed was
gone so now I don't know what to do
I just been post-meeting from like
health healthy [ __ ] places I don't
know who the [ __ ] knows but whatever
guys we're all gonna get through this I
just wanted me I'm hoping I know I was
teasing some people there but I hope you
come away from this feeling better all
right it's hilarious I just did a bunch
of negative [ __ ] but like we're gonna be
fine okay if China the size that it is
with all of those people stacked up the
way that they are was able to stop it
you know and then you know have it the
cases start to decline we're gonna be
able to do it all right and this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] media is absolutely I love
this [ __ ] because you can put it on one
person that hand sanitizer guy the
amount of [ __ ] that that guy got and
that will follow him for the rest of his
[ __ ] life but all of these [ __ ]
news anchors who are scaring the [ __ ]
out of you you're gonna come right back
to sit there and [ __ ] watch them the
second this thing's over
they're terrible [ __ ] people and it
is a horribly perverted [ __ ] industry
this is coming from a complete [ __ ]
[ __ ] telling you this alright for the
last [ __ ] time CNN is not news Fox
News is not news okay that is the
opinion of a very small handful of
[ __ ] people and they are not holding
people accountable alright remember the
big [ __ ] you know banking crisis in
2008 I want you to name me one [ __ ]
bankers name that took a [ __ ] bonus
after that [ __ ] which was all of our
money
they did what the [ __ ] they did
knowingly doing what they did name one
[ __ ] bankers name this [ __ ] poor
bastard it is the thing about the hand
sanitizer guy alright I'm not trying to
be an [ __ ] here but the guy he's has
the ultimate dude I called it
he took a major [ __ ] risk this guy
bought seventeen thousand seven hundred
dollars what the [ __ ] hand sanitizer
what if this [ __ ] didn't happen what in
the [ __ ] was he gonna do with that
alright he [ __ ] called it he got
ahead of it this is where he [ __ ] up
he priced gouged he shouldn't have done
that he got greedy he got greedy like
all [ __ ] crooks - alright I'm not I'm
listening I'm not [ __ ] I'm just being
funny about this guy I just love how he
got [ __ ] but all these [ __ ] [ __ ] in
the media who scared the living [ __ ] out
of people like the way they're reporting
like if you look on Twitter the way they
go death deaths from [ __ ] coronavirus
increasing in Italy after they showed
you that the streets are barren yeah
that's what's gonna happen
everybody's quarantine the death rates
gonna go up it's gonna crest and then
it's gonna come back down again
alright the media caused the run on food
they [ __ ] flipped everybody out they
freaked everybody out and and they do
nothing absolutely nothing other than
Fanning the flames to try and get you to
continue watching so they keep making
[ __ ] money those Cosi [ __ ] right and
then what do they do then they take the
hand sanitizer guy who's doing the exact
[ __ ] same thing they're doing
profiting off the misery of people
during this [ __ ] pandemic and then
they throw a how could you do that I
just wish he was like the same way you
guys can get after all you can make the
whole [ __ ] her run over the cliff god
I wish he said that instead of State did
he wear a shirt that said family man
[Music]
it's one of the greats that's right up
there with Harvey Weinstein using the
Walker huh how much is that [ __ ]
vindictive son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
praying this thing just burns through
the whole country
I bet he's getting all the other
prisoners in Rikers Island all stirred
up I didn't know what he sounds like I
don't know if they're talking it's gotta
burn through all them the guards are
outside they're gonna catch him
we need to steal a key let them all die
then we'll let ourselves out and we'll
rape who ever left anyway so anyway how
much time have I done in this [ __ ] I
know there's a lot of people a lot of
sports junkies out there like oh my god
what am I gonna do what the [ __ ] am I
gonna do just [ __ ] they they're
showing all the old games MotoGP just
put up the top ten motorcycle races ever
you know there's something to do oh you
got a little keyboard little piano in
your house yeah someday I'm gonna learn
how to play it sit down and learn how to
play it right you think I'm not playing
drums like a [ __ ] lunatic I'm having
a great time when I don't think about
the food situation but he doesn't think
they're gonna like what the government's
doing is great
they shut everything down you're gonna
be able to [ __ ] an order takeout all
right they're still gonna deliver water
even if you don't have [ __ ] water
they can [ __ ] you got tap water right
you can boil it sanitize it you're gonna
be fine we're all gonna drop some pounds
we're gonna be lean and mean for the
first time in a long time America is
gonna be lean and mean and make no
mistake people around the world I'm not
talking about you this podcast is not
for you anymore it's everything you
could do some yoga you could come back
to work [ __ ] ripped the granite
everybody's gonna be too afraid to touch
each other intimately you know sexual
tension is gonna be crazy not to have
[ __ ] jerk-off boots this time next
month hopefully we all come back to work
everybody's looking like [ __ ] little
gone they got stubble going the guys
right the chicks got the thigh gap going
I think this is my call
after this pandemic there is gonna be
another baby boom it's gonna be another
baby boom that's what it's gonna be you
know the first time it happened was
because people fought a world war for
[ __ ] five six years right with us
nowadays we're so [ __ ] pampered here
it's just gonna because we had to stay
and we had to stay inside for like what
six weeks I guess I don't [ __ ] know
anyway it's a good time to get arrested
anybody out there if you're really in a
jam for food three hots and a cot you
know there's always a solution so anyway
I want to hear from some Doomsday
Preppers how psyched are you or other
people that have like the panic room
that I don't like that [ __ ] pantry
with all the cans of beans and the
quinoa
right good on you you did it especially
you know the the men and women who are
with somebody who were like oh my god
you're crazy you're acting crazy
you got your tinfoil hat on right like
yeah you guys used to always say to me I
should have had a bunch of bees away why
didn't I do it now I got all this
[ __ ] corned beef I don't know what
the [ __ ] could do with it's gonna be
bland people I all I got is salt and
pepper left I don't even have a freezer
big enough to [ __ ] put the thing and
so I'm gonna have to cook it and then
stick it in bags and then [ __ ] freeze
it what if we're all gonna laugh about
it I mean if they could survive the
Depression The Grapes of Wrath [ __ ] in
you know the Spanish flu we're gonna be
fine so I'm just [ __ ] around I'm
joking
alright how funny is advertising now on
a [ __ ] podcast alright everybody
zip recruiter old zip recruiter sorry
that was the coronavirus version Zep
recruiter everybody according to zip
recruit a research nearly 3/4 of
employees say there
finding it difficult to file open
positions nearly 3/4 employs say they're
finding it difficult to alter fill open
positions example of bold steps they
have taken to hire 68 percent of
employers have raised their wages 23
percent have increased their benefits if
you have a difficult role to fill no
matter what your industry hire with zip
recruiter and now you can try zip
recruiter for free EDD zip cruder
dot-com / bird sorry this is the
apocalypse version of this zip recruit
ascends your job to 100 job sites but
they don't stop there with their
powerful powerful matching technology
this is a great way to try to hire
somebody through the internet well they
won't breathe on you zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right skills and experience for your
job and actively invites them to apply
you can even add screening questions to
your job listings so you can filter
candidates and focus on the best ones
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter can get it quality quality
candidate within the first day to try
zip kurta for free my listeners can go
to zip recruit comp / / that zip
recruiter dot-com / / zi p re crui ter
comm / / zip recruit the smartest way to
hire here is one of the advantages
because living in the middle of nowhere
right now is great it's always been
great and for a long time i have envied
people that live in the middle of
nowhere you know who can look at nature
the way i look at a skyline and be like
wow isn't that beautiful it isn't
beautiful
it's a [ __ ] pandemic waiting to
happen and they're out there in the
middle of nowhere right they got all
that game and all that food right they
got berries and [ __ ] coming out of the
[ __ ] grass whatever [ __ ] berry
grows on a berry tree
right strawberry trees forever making no
strawberries what are you saying I live
an alternative lifestyle I'm eating
[ __ ] mate you don't know who you're
dealing with I gives no [ __ ] either
I'll go head to head with a [ __ ] RAM
you watch me you [ __ ] watch me give
that RAM [ __ ] concussion protocol
he ain't starting next week you can bet
your [ __ ] sweet bippy on that anyway
there's a bunch of [ __ ] hostile
emails that I got it's funny watching
just peep like the level of hostility in
the [ __ ] emails right that I got this
week just [ __ ] people angry they're
afraid the herd is running and they need
to target I know who to go after I'm
going after a podcaster podcast host
people try to maintain maintain your
cool as there's plenty of food to order
it will be brought to your house like a
king I think that you know here's the
thing - if you're worried about money
and rent nobody's gonna pay their
[ __ ] rent alright it's it it's it's
it it's gonna it's gonna be fine okay
shut up Joe bartnik if you watched the
morning's Kate was saying out all the
NHL teams except for the Buffalo Sabres
for whatever reason are taking care of
their employees which is inspiring me to
do the same thing at all things comedy I
think we can all [ __ ] help each other
out and I don't know be the person
that's keeping everybody calm because I
gotta be honest you flipping the [ __ ]
out is really not gonna help anybody so
I went down to the grocery store and
there was like [ __ ] nothing left I
bite nothing there was still stuff I
mean I got some gabagool I got a little
[ __ ] cheese sticks I got uh I got
some peanut butter and that was a big
score I got some almonds and I got some
Vlada you know so I'm alright
I don't mind coming back lean and mean
just in time for the summer people this
pandemic hit us at the perfect [ __ ]
time we are all gonna be in swimsuits
swimsuit we are all gonna be in swimsuit
safe shape I can't even talk we were all
gonna be in swimsuits shape the reason
why I can't top talk is because I'm
[ __ ] it's not because of the lack of
calories that I'm [ __ ] taking in it's
because I wear that [ __ ] Invisalign
thing Invisalign all right now let's
talk about Invisalign
it's [ __ ] tremendous it definitely
straightens out your teeth but they
don't talk to you about the back nine
all right they act like okay this is
gonna suck it's gonna be a little
[ __ ] annoying
with the pain moving your teeth or
whatever it's gonna be a pain in the ass
to eat or whatever but in the end you
can have these beautiful [ __ ]
straight teeth right like a military
[ __ ] dress rehearsal it's gonna look
great right in the end it's gonna be
worth it okay which it is and I'm not
anti Invisalign especially during times
like these they just don't tell you
about the back end the back end is that
once your teeth are straight they're not
going to stay straight if you stop
wearing them you have to wear your
invisible you get like a retainer that
you have to wear like you're supposed to
you know he's supposed to wear it like I
just wear it at night and I try to go
two days in a row
I usually go a day but if you'd skip two
days that third day it starts to hurt
again when you wear it all right there
you go I think this is a time to be
truthful and honest about information
and that is the most honest thing but
it's totally worth it it's absolutely
worth it my teeth I look like I look
like Farrah Fawcett if she transitioned
I always thought she had beautiful teeth
you know she probably did but when I was
a kid in the 70s those were beautiful
teeth you know although I will tell you
right my favorite of all the Charlie's
Angels was definitely Kate Jackson you
know and I still think she's a looker
man I had a crush on her from time she
was on the rookies
that about him she was married to Mike
Danko the flats that was one of the
great [ __ ] TV character names of all
time Mike Danko it's cuz he couldn't say
Mike [ __ ] oh forget it he's got a he's
got a long [ __ ] he's got a dick he
names it Hank it was all in there and Oh
does he bang that [ __ ] nurse Mike
Danko anyway by the way as I gave credit
to almost all those [ __ ] people to
that you know we're about owning guns
and all this type of [ __ ] now it all
makes sense I gave my wife [ __ ] for it
are you still happy we don't have a gun
watching these [ __ ] people two days
into this [ __ ] thing descend on the
grocery store like chickens all have
[ __ ] the coronavirus like they're not
gonna keep laying eggs like they're not
gonna keep slaughtering [ __ ] cattle
there's gonna be food there's gonna be
more shipments of food if everybody
would just [ __ ] relax you know what
the funny thing is is people are gonna
[ __ ] keep hoarding food is they're
throwing out the food that they hoarded
from the week before that's how [ __ ]
nuts people are stop doing that all
right just [ __ ] it if everybody just
chilled went down to the grocery store
about a week's worth of [ __ ] groceries
went back stayed away from each other we
could have a wonderful two-week vacation
you know but that's not how it works man
they people like the drama talking all
kinds of [ __ ] people I don't know
there's no [ __ ] sports I just got to
keep going with this so just just
[ __ ] bear with me here all right they
like the [ __ ] drama the same way you
know is if you [ __ ] if you watch one
of those guy we're watching this cooking
show right yesterday watching this
[ __ ] cooking show and it's a stupid
goddamn contest thing and now they got
it with kids and they're having him
freak out run around all over the
kitchen and if I just said to my wife my
lovely wife I was like yeah can we just
put on a show where they they have time
to cook it and they just show us how to
cook it and I put on one of my favorites
of all time the Rachael Ray Show back in
the day when I was a single man in my
early 30s way way
way way back almost 20 [ __ ] years ago
I used to watch her show and I'm Rachael
Ray I make 15 minute meals dude I
[ __ ] called it with her I knew she
was gonna blow up and we watched her
make fish tacos god damn who's [ __ ]
tremendous why do I keep hearing this
noise what is that it's a [ __ ] wire
running on my goddamn sweatshirt can you
guys hear that you probably can't hear
it's probably just in my [ __ ]
headphones now that I just shut off the
recorder alright okay everything's still
going and is another thing too you can
watch some movies that you haven't seen
in a while or always wanted to watch I
watched one of my favorite movies of all
time this is required watching this week
you got to watch Jack Lemmon and Shirley
MacLaine in the apartment it was made in
1959 written by Billy Wilder and
somebody else who I can't remember came
out in 1960 in the subject matter of it
it's just so far ahead of time that's
all so just to see like how people
behave that way back then like why I
just thought that was more like after
the summer the Summer of Love everybody
walked around with that dick out [ __ ]
but you gotta watch this [ __ ] movie
the apartment alright Jack Lemmon
amazing and then if you want to see what
Jack Lemmon is in as an actor his great
as he is in that movie if you then watch
Glengarry Glen Ross which is 30 years or
so after he did the apartment he is 30
years better he never stopped improving
that guy was a huge inspiration checked
out anybody got any movies that you can
recommend you know that's another thing
too that you could [ __ ] you could do
that's that list that they always come
out the hundred greatest movies of all
time oh you know what I actually have a
list from Pete Davidson's dad he made an
incredible list when we were doing that
movie which is supposed to be coming out
in June I believe you know if we're not
all dead first
it's the flu it's the flu rebooted
that's all it is it's the flu rebooted
you're like remember when they brought
Will and Grace back it's the same
[ __ ] thing
it's the same thing we just don't have a
vaccine for it yet we're gonna get a
vaccine for it all right
this is this is the bitters of something
comforting aids didn't kill us wipe us
out it's what I should say it killed a
lot of people but it didn't you know a
disease spread a fatal disease spread
through [ __ ] didn't kill us everybody
[ __ ] everybody you know how psycho
asexual people when that happened I'd
say right now man if you are an asexual
doomsday prepper with a gun license then
you're over the age of 45 50 you don't
have a line on your face from stress I
don't [ __ ] anything I will shoot if you
if you come on my property
I've got a panic room that's the way to
do it hey what do you think my buddy
Joel Osteen's doing right now huh
do you think he's hoarding like
eucharist I think that that's how he
stays so [ __ ] thin anyway you know I
think it just eats eucharist every week
the body cries right and he just [ __ ]
slides him in there you know he eats him
the way I eat [ __ ] Girl Scout cookie
mints he eats a whole sleeve of [ __ ]
Eucharist every day and then that's it
and then the stress of what the [ __ ] am
I gonna tell these people this week did
I mean the genius of that guy in all
preachers I gotta say the fact that this
is [ __ ] book that has been devoured
it's just been [ __ ] devoured and
you're picking the same [ __ ]
story's the same [ __ ] stories right
and you got to come with your [ __ ]
angle your spin on the thing it's really
it's an it's an amazing art form and I
think that that's why they were all
saying he's coming back because they
need the guy to come back they need some
new stories right but then you got to be
afraid when when when Jesus comes back
if you're a preacher he just shut you
down nobody's listening to your show
anymore they gonna listen to Jesus
Christ right Jesus Christ coming back to
preachers personally is is for me as if
Eddie Murphy started doing stand-up
again it's like I don't matter anymore
I am the Joel Osteen of [ __ ] stand-up
comedy and I challenge anybody that's
actually not true I deliver my jokes
with my eyes open because I'm too dumb
to know that I'm full of [ __ ] actually I
kind of realize I'm full of [ __ ] anyway
so what have I been working on drum wise
you know my life's work the good times
bad time thing and my foot has never
been faster not saying it's fast but
it's never been [ __ ] faster I've been
getting caught up on some podcasts you
want to let's do a great [ __ ]
interview Marc Maron WTF podcast what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] ATS
you gotta listen to his interview with
Don Gavin I and I had Don Gavin on my
podcast - I actually think mark has a
better interview if I'm gonna be honest
like I just loved how marked he talked
about like like I don't just because he
mark was there okay mark was [ __ ]
there I mean I came in in 1992 I started
after the boom mark was [ __ ] there he
opened up for these guys during the
height of the booze and coke 80s I mean
it was [ __ ] bananas I mean I just sit
there when I started out and I would
listen to guys
once mark finally decided I was worthy
of talking to him I love him who by the
way man he [ __ ] I forgot to give him
a shout-out on the [ __ ] Dean Del Ray
ACDC thing Mark Maret [ __ ] murdered
it Marc Maron is a guitar player who
does [ __ ] stand-up he's another guy
he could have [ __ ] done that if he
[ __ ] wanted to you know anyway he
[ __ ] murdered but his his interview
here of of what's his face a [ __ ] dog
Gavin is incredible because when he
brings up the drinking you know Don is
one of those guys who just [ __ ] you
know he likes to have a few and I think
on Rogen's he Rogen asked amigos did you
have you ever tried to quit drinking and
he was like yeah no I haven't he's doing
fine the [ __ ] guy is doing fine and
he's absolutely [ __ ] hilarious and he
is the reason that I have a [ __ ]
career cuz guys like him started the
Boston comedy scene but if you want to
just listen to an incredible incredible
[ __ ] interview listen to Marc Maron's
podcast where he interviews Don Gavin I
absolutely [ __ ] loved it
alright so let's see you guys ready you
guys ready for some [ __ ] some hostile
[ __ ] emails there we go alright
cancel be responsible and please cancel
your dates for the rest of the year this
undeniably affects the whole world oh my
god I I so want to talk to the person
that sent me this [ __ ] email who are
you talking to well what what what
[ __ ] panic mine state are you in
uh-huh
do you think it's up to me to cancel all
of these [ __ ] dates you [ __ ] dope
I haven't cancelled any dates they were
all canceled
for me and they will be continued to be
canceled as the government sees fit I'm
doing exactly what the [ __ ] they're
telling me to do and the second the
government tells me it's okay for me to
be dancing monkey boy again I'm gonna
put on my little hat and go out there
and do my dance I don't [ __ ] need you
to give me a goddamn [ __ ] lecture on
some [ __ ] because you're assuming that
I'm not gonna [ __ ] listen to people
so you can feel does it make you feel
like you have control be responsible and
pick up lock yourself how much [ __ ]
butter and milk did you buy the other
day be responsible shut the [ __ ] up I
fell
I [ __ ] hate I hate people who like
something's already being handled and
then they they [ __ ] act like you know
I know I don't need a talking-to I know
what the [ __ ] to do I didn't go down to
the supermarket and buy nine months
worth of [ __ ] food like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] a bunch of perishable [ __ ]
goods I didn't do that
you just bought beans I respect what you
did be responsible and please cancel
your dates for the rest of the you shut
the [ __ ] up okay it is that what you and
your lack of a medical degree have
[ __ ] surmised after watching 24 hour
[ __ ] news that tried to scare the
[ __ ] out of you really should i cancel a
date I don't have any [ __ ] dates and
December your dumb [ __ ] alright here we
go and here's another one don't cancel
hi Reno is a low-risk zone according to
this other person who is in a doctor and
no events are being canceled at this
time please come it's a family event for
us okay we got to the motivation in the
end it's a family event for us
they've all been can't it's all my [ __ ]
through March has been canceled
I was going to the Masters that has been
delayed postponed whatever you want to
call it
my ass up right now my Atlanta and
Nashville dates still exist
I highly doubt they're going to happen
but if the government decides by the end
of March that this it's [ __ ] safe I
am going to go do them and I believe a
bunch of people are going to want to go
out and laugh but March is a rap March
is a rap so there you go all right be a
leader all right
be a leader oh look at this [ __ ] be a
lead like how [ __ ] desperate is the
world right now that somebody is writing
me to be a leader I don't lead I'm not a
leader I'm a [ __ ] idiot I went to
summer school every [ __ ] year of high
school
except sophomore year cuz she hooked me
up and senior year what was the point I
wasn't getting into a good school anyway
alright but yep I I love you bill but
you are sending the wrong message to all
your thousands of fans by downplaying
the koko vid 19 by like when people they
want to sound [ __ ] you know co feed
19 fighters I mean the coronavirus the
Rona is a young kids call it it's true
that 80% of people that contact the
virus will be fine but it's also true
that this strain is 10 to 15 times more
deadly than the seasonal flu and how do
you know that how do you know that
because of [ __ ] people said and then
it'll change tomorrow I'm just telling
everybody to not [ __ ] panic okay I'm
not out there running around I've stayed
home what the [ __ ] are you doing giving
me a [ __ ] lecture I'm the one telling
everybody to [ __ ] calm down I never
said don't do what the [ __ ] the
government said I'm actually saying do
it alright and not to mention [ __ ] is
also [ __ ] is changing by the day be a
leader alright let's let's continue
through this is really [ __ ] annoying
me I really hope somebody sneezes on you
sir or ma'am okay this this put did
Obama bow okay this puts the other 20%
at risk you know first of all I just
love that the numbers work out so
perfectly here
80% 10 to 15 times 20%
whenever the numbers are round that's
usually like me all the time 90% I love
that number I don't know why it's just
my favorite percentage I always use that
whenever there's round numbers okay and
the person is not standing in front of a
wall that has a bunch of doctorates
behind it and wearing a [ __ ] lab coat
actually in a real hospital that means
they're pulling [ __ ] out of their ass
that they have spliced together through
watching 24 hour news networks panics
[ __ ] text threads with their friends
and [ __ ] that they overheard whispered
at the ground zero of panic grocery
stores
all right this puts the other 20% not 19
not 21 percent 20 percent at serious
risks of hospitalization I realize all
of this I don't need your lecture I get
it
not to mention hospitals could be
overwhelmed by the millions of elderly
citizens and others you mean if they all
came down within a week that would
present a problem and others with weak
immune systems that need attention
it isn't about you or me but rather the
other 20% no dude this this whole
[ __ ] email is about you this whole
thing is about you you don't give a [ __ ]
about those [ __ ] people anyways
please be considerate real people are
dying and if the world didn't take such
drastic precautions millions more would
die just think world leaders are
willingly putting us into a recession
because they think that's the best
option oh boy just think about that for
a minute
anyways bill please be more careful with
the things you say on Twitter in this
pocket go people take your version of
the facts as truth who are you talking
about my job is to be a [ __ ] comedian
and that's what I'm doing
around trying to keep people loose and
calm I never said I was going out there
I have done every [ __ ] thing that
they said okay I still think it's
ridiculous that a bunch of people went
down and bought a month's worth of
[ __ ] food [ __ ] over everybody else
alright so go [ __ ] yourself be a leader
go [ __ ] yourself anyway alright I think
I handled that in an adult way what did
I tweet out I tweeted out I go you know
I think what Tom Hanks doesn't die
everybody's gonna [ __ ] chill and that
was that was right to say in that moment
with what we knew about the [ __ ]
virus because everyone was acting like
it was gonna kill everybody and now we
know ok now what it's really dangerous
is people with weakened immune systems
and older [ __ ] people so he's gonna
be fine even though he's an older fella
himself he's a famous over fella with
with [ __ ] millions okay if [ __ ]
hiv/aids doesn't kill magic I'm going
out on a [ __ ] limb the corona virus
doesn't take old Tommy Boy alright once
again ok it's a great joke ok these are
pandemic jokes people you didn't have to
[ __ ] deal with them I am NOT a
[ __ ] leader
alright grow the [ __ ] up the leaders are
the people that you elected listen to
them why the [ __ ] would you listen to a
stand-up comedian about what to do
during a [ __ ] who do you listen to I
don't know I don't listen to anybody who
doesn't have a medical degree
ok I don't I listen to the government
who's listening to the guys with the
white coats and that's what the [ __ ] I'm
listening to and I'm hoping that they're
doing the right thing that's what the
[ __ ] I'm doing all right
[ __ ] goddamn dope alright alright we
got all right now let's here we go some
more panic emails alright from a real
flat earther I love this guy
staying on the subject Billy Boy the
thing is there is no space that's what
people mean by NASA stealing money ste e
Li ng stealing money the Sun and the
moon
are inside the firmament dude this is
[ __ ] amazing I got to look this up
what the [ __ ] is affirming you know what
I don't love about this [ __ ] this
flatter first their stuff
that was the first time I just went
eight straight seconds without thinking
about the pandemic people do yourself a
favor get a flat earther in your [ __ ]
life
okay firmament the heavens or the sky
especially when regarded as a tangible
thing oh god I need to know all about
the firmament okay
in biblical cosmology I didn't know they
did facials back then sorry
biblical cosmology is the biblical
writers conception of the cosmos as
organized structured entity including
its origin order meaning and destiny
I'll back when they were writing the
Bible okay all right what are we in the
biblical cosmology the firmament is the
vast solid dome created by God on the
second day to divide the primal sea
called teh home at a home at a all into
upper and lower portions so that the dry
land could appear then God said oh my
god I'm gonna start quoting scripture
during a pandemic on my podcast this is
really gonna freak people out I'm just
reading firmament on Wikipedia you can
follow along and then God said let there
be a firmament in the midst of the
waters and let it divide the waters from
the waters
it doesn't make sense this is why I
don't go to church honey divide the
waters from the waters
thus God made the firmament and the
divided and divided the waters which
were under the firmament do you mean the
land I thought this guy's talking about
the sky from the waters which were above
the firmament and so it was
sorry actually accidentally shut up the
recorder or so it was and it was so
sorry and God called the firmament
heaven so the evening in the morning
were the second day
I mean if anybody can tell me what the
[ __ ] I just read God said let me let
there be firmament in the midst of the
waters and let's let it divide the
waters from the waters thus God made the
firmament and if I don't know what it is
the word firmament is recorded in Middle
English narrative based on Scripture
dated 1250 it appeared in the King James
Bible the word firmament is used to
translate a word in Biblical Hebrew what
the [ __ ] meaning to beat or spread out
thinly the process of making a dish by
hammering thin a lump of metal like most
Asian people the Hebrews believe the sky
was a solid dome with the Sun Moon
planets and stars embedded in it okay
now I know what it is the Hebrews
regarded the earth as a plane or a hill
figured like a hemisphere that makes God
a lot scarier like he's right there
swimming on water
okay the earth was a planar hill figured
like a hemisphere swimming on water over
this is an arch arch the solid vault of
heaven to this vault are fastened the
lights the Stars so slight is the
elevation that birds may rise to it and
fly along its expanse
that's fascinating
that's a whole different way of looking
at the world all right okay there is no
space it does not exist there is a dome
over the earth basically a forcefield
people believe this is the firmament
from the Bible now you were caught up on
the motive and I understand this but
you can't deny the facts based on not
knowing the motive did you just prove
something there I think I need to eat
some corned beef or something I can't I
can't even think today a detective
doesn't walk into a room see a dead guy
on the floor who was shot in the head
with no gun in the room and say well
nobody had motive motive to kill this
guy so he's not dead and nobody did I
could go right back here with that
analogy a detective doesn't walk in on a
murder case that was already solved and
then try to resolve it huh
there's my gumshoe [ __ ] metaphor how
do you like that one all right no the
fact is he was murdered so now try to
figure out the motive this is what
people did at first they thought it was
flat I evidently and that there was a
firmament that you could you know if you
quit tall enough you could reach up if
you're a bird you could fly into it then
people like oh now wait a second well
how do you explain like telescopes and
[ __ ] seeing all of this stuff are they
just misinterpreting other galaxies and
black holes and all of that or is that
all just [ __ ] because I'd be honest
with you I will agree with you on this
thing I don't know if Jupiter's out
there I've never seen it I've just been
told that it's there okay so I'm not
gonna wag my finger at you that way but
I mean I'm kind of going out on a limb
here that you know trying to get
everybody on the same page around the
world with the same lie you know to
finance NASA
why does Vietnam give a [ __ ] about NASA
making money are they getting a cut man
all right money is he only is only a
small part of this description there's a
much bigger and more important reason
for know here we go I can drop the bomb
on you but you probably wouldn't believe
it anyway so I won't
come on don't don't take your bomb and
go home now bill oh oh I'm getting a
lecture here there has never been an
experiment done to this day to prove
that the earth has a curvature or is
moving that is 100% fact okay dude
you're really [ __ ] with everything
that I've been told because I gotta be
honest with you in the sense of what
you're saying I never looked up whether
there's ever been an experiment I felt
when they got in boats and they sailed
that away and came back around the other
way they were like well goddamn this
[ __ ] ramp that should be a
major red flag for you I just love how
you assume that just because you now say
this that you just proved something to
me send me a link send me evidence to
back up what you're saying other than
that this is just crazy talk anyway it's
a theory which is a fine
which is fine theories are good but if
you point out that this stuff is just a
theory and was never proven people get
pissed at you well it's what's ok well
then where is where is the study that
prove what you're saying is true ok why
isn't there a link to that maybe he gets
to it as smart as we are today and if
the earth really was a globe there would
be a thousand ways to prove it have you
ever flown around the world cuz I have
all right what did the pilot do did he
just subtly just sort of like subtly go
to the right to fly all the way back the
long way we did run out of jet fuel and
we didn't have to refuel video isn't
evidence because it can be faked in the
same way that Bigfoot or Loch Ness
monster videos aren't proof of them NASA
and space videos aren't proof of space I
believe in the science
method observable testable repeatable
alright well then let's do this with
your theory there are many ways to
procure here we go there are many ways
to prove the earth is flat and
stationary water always finds its level
meaning the top of still water is always
flat no matter what scale they use to
lose water as a leveling tool before
lasers as earth is 80% water
there are many cities mountains
lighthouses etcetera that can be seen
way farther than I thought it was
gravity I don't I don't understand I
don't get any of this I mean I'd be
honest with you I don't know why water's
level this is beyond my paygrade I don't
think about this [ __ ] alright
but videos can be faked and then videos
can also give evidence you know if I
showed you a video of a dead body you
wouldn't believe that the guy was dead I
like when you do you think World War two
didn't happen because you're not there
to with witness it you can't touch it
you can't test it it never happened
because all there is now is just movies
of it so does that mean that didn't
happen you can't believe it because it's
fake cuz it can be faked I know this is
this is what I just wish I had some sort
of scientific background cuz then I
could tell if this guy is actually a
hundred percent right and that or what I
think is right is what I've been told I
don't [ __ ] know and earth is 80%
water
there are many cities mountains
lighthouses etc that can be seen way
farther than would be possible on a
globe with dimensions they give us i
100% disagree with that 100% [ __ ]
disagree with that that that is the
first thing that i can 100% disagree
with so the earth is either flat or
astronomically bigger than they say it
is the North Star does not move
in the sky ever this proves we are not
moving well what about everything else
that is moving everything else rotates
around that something is moving this
proves we are not the Northstar they
picked that out because it's at the
[ __ ] epicenter I think of the way
we're lined up and that's how you used
to guide yourself by the stars in the
northern atmosphere let me ask you this
sir do you sail or ma'am do you sail do
you know how to [ __ ] anyway there are
many ways to booking I I just I am I
supposed to keep reading this what about
the rest of it that turns so what is the
Sun do this is fascinating where does
the Sun go when it goes down is that God
just putting on a dimmer huh does he
move it across the sky
who's moving we're not moving so the
earth is either flat or astronomical
instated the North Star does not move in
the sky ever this proves we are not
moving because the earth is supposedly
supposedly moves an astronomical
distance around the Sun each year and
tilts on its axis each year also so this
would be impossible gravity does not
exist this is just a theory that it was
never proven am I being trolled here and
a stupid one that makes no sense at that
gravity supposedly holds down
skyscrapers and boulders and stones that
weigh hundreds of tons but can't hold
down a black bird or a fruit fly or
butterfly how does that makes oh my god
and this is where I tap up okay you need
to take a science class buddy okay all
right hypocrisy from bill burr all right
and more angry emails the pandemic is my
fault I need to be a leader I need to
cancel all of my shows for the rest of
the year all right hypocrisy is from
Bilborough long time
listener got nothing but good [ __ ] to
say about you and the family oh this is
he comes the window helped from being a
heavy drinker to less than a moderate
amount that's awesome f is for family is
amazing enough of the dick sucking you
are so full of [ __ ]
oh yeah admittedly admit it I always say
I'm full of [ __ ] I can't read out loud I
can't spell I'm a [ __ ]
I went to summer school I'm an idiot I
say this all the time it's your dumb ass
that took me seriously what are you
gonna take me to task for sir because
there's no eggs left at your [ __ ]
grocer
you are so full of [ __ ] when you talk
about all your corporations and how
horrible they are you are in bed getting
[ __ ] by one that you do your specials
with you probably even get priority
shares for Netflix I'll do I do I get
stock options alright
I didn't know that I'll have to cash in
on some of those it's amazing how you
talk about massive amounts of [ __ ] but
still sell out to the corporate man oh
you know I I deserve a lot of [ __ ]
finger-wagging
but not on this one don't get me wrong I
do the same [ __ ] if Netflix came with
some money you wouldn't hear me bitching
about corporations like you do oh my god
oh this guy this guy's getting a
talking-to at the end of this but you're
a little full of [ __ ] in this one area
you go Disney
I'll watch Pryor on Sunset for the rest
of my life nothing new ever again trying
to explain yourself out of this would be
just as fun as hearing you talk about
the Federal Reserve which I completely
agree with and completely please tell
miss Mia to go [ __ ] you and go [ __ ]
yourself just a foo YouTube ATC I don't
what that means um okay I don't know
what I don't know what that I don't know
where the [ __ ] to begin on this okay
first of all as far as the Netflix thing
do you know where I tried to take my
last special do you have any [ __ ]
idea
you don't do you do you I tried to put
it on YouTube I was gonna try to make a
deal with YouTube which is that also a
corporation I believe it is I don't know
I was trying to go there because I was
looking at Netflix like it was too
[ __ ] crowded over there alright I'll
go over to [ __ ] YouTube and I'll put
it here right and they were all about
doing it until they saw my act and then
their balls pulled up inside of them and
there that me to stuff we're gonna the
advertiser is gonna get flagged and the
whole [ __ ] thing went away so I tried
to go somewhere else and by the way also
I have the all things comedy [ __ ]
Network we created a [ __ ] company to
help out comedians who are getting
picked apart by these businessman [ __ ]
I'm fighting the good fight out here
alright I tried to go to mom-and-pop
stores but the bottom line is
corporations have [ __ ] taken over I
have to [ __ ] play ball on some level
I'm not a hunter I'm not finished man
I don't know what to do and yes I am
[ __ ] full of [ __ ] but let me tell you
this is you sit there [ __ ] sitting
there acting like I'm [ __ ] over there
wearing a [ __ ] a Netflix varsity
jacket cashing in my [ __ ] stock
options I don't have any of that alright
so go [ __ ] yourself
and I love that Disney entered the
[ __ ] the the [ __ ] streaming thing
this is great you can't just have one
World Bank you can't have one streaming
service it's great that there's gonna be
competition out there okay that's all
I'm saying I don't know what else what
what the [ __ ] do you want from me I'm
playing the game just like everybody
else but am I gonna [ __ ] sit there
and not make fun of corporations in the
way they treat people absolutely I'm
running a company the opposite [ __ ]
way of a corporation I do my best that's
all you can get for me so if you don't
think I'm a [ __ ] hypocrite you know
who's a hypocrite is you listening to me
why don't you put your [ __ ] thumbs
will you goddamn mouth is as your
[ __ ] sitting here trying to tear me a
new [ __ ] [ __ ] about what a [ __ ]
dick I am as I'm sitting here trying to
[ __ ] raise money for public schools
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I'm [ __ ] bringing [ __ ] Direct
homeless people you [ __ ] [ __ ] and
your [ __ ] paint me out like I'm
sitting there with my [ __ ] my gold
l'm a [ __ ] loafers but my feet up on
a [ __ ] desk over and netflix is that
what the [ __ ] you think you're talking
to here
them's fightin words buddy I'll tell you
right now I will virtually bitch-slap
you with that with a [ __ ] wit or
whatever I have [ __ ] left with a
[ __ ] handful of uncooked corned beef
my favorite thing is you probably have
it wasn't stock option one with that I
want to go back to that you're so full
of [ __ ] we type of code remember then
then you probably get priority shares
[Music]
you know what I have not ascended to
that level yes I work for corporations I
do and I get [ __ ] by corporations if
you knew right now how bad I'm getting
this guy's trying to [ __ ] me and some
other [ __ ] deal right now [ __ ] it's
it's like it's just this [ __ ] guy's
trying to charge me $1,200 to use the
copier in his office I'm like we have
one at ATC and then they do that [ __ ]
you know I'm insulted by this line of
questioning anytime anybody says that
I'm offended I'm offended it's like
that's cuz you can't defend your
position this is how business is done
all right
raps getting your car rap so you don't
have to worry about chip paint reminds
me of my grandmother rapping your couch
and then that 70s thick polyurethane
coating fair enough fair enough I don't
know I hang out with Dean Del Ray he
gets me to buy [ __ ] that I probably
don't need to buy but that's the genius
of Dean anyways that is the podcast
Jesus Christ people one [ __ ] eight
days into a goddamn pandemic and then
everybody you're a [ __ ] hypocrite you
should be a leader I mean look at this
[ __ ] a lair I can't wait to see what
you guys [ __ ] take out on me next
[ __ ] week all right oh by the way I
forgot this [ __ ] let's do a little
extra-long here God knows we're all
[ __ ] staying at home I have gen-x
shut up yes you know it's been great as
watching Millennials and [ __ ] baby
boomers yelling at each other and the
Generation X we're just sitting right
right in the [ __ ] middle
nobody givin us [ __ ] and now some stupid
Generation X people now have to start
spouting off that we are perfectly built
for the pandemic because we were
latchkey kids and doing all the dumb
[ __ ] that should do which is you
basically you're creating us vs. them
you could have made a funny joke about a
I grew up in Generation X I was a
latchkey kid I think I'm ready for this
if anybody wants some advice God knows I
got the time I'll give it to you instead
of coming at it was like we're [ __ ]
better than you are so now I'm looking
I'm predicting right now a giant
Generation X backlash because I just
think Millennials and baby boomers are
running out of ways to trash each other
I mean baby boomers are calling people
who aren't Millennials millenials
Millennials and people who aren't
Millennials are calling boomers who
aren't boomers boomers you know anybody
who's old as a Boomer I've actually been
called a boomer okay boomer anyways and
then I just like because that what I've
got what I do like about okay boomer is
I think it actually bothers baby boomers
so I'm all for continuing doing that and
I also like being called the Boomer it's
[ __ ] great because it's like oh
that's cool I was just a [ __ ] and
somebody else got blamed all right so
anyways people do what the government
says stay away for people stay home
we'll knock this [ __ ] thing out don't
get freaked out by the news where they
say death tolls are rising they're gonna
rise and then they're gonna cascade
they're gonna do this isn't gonna take
us out we're gonna be fine
we [ __ ] survived y2k the AIDS
epidemic sighs the Spanish flu
tuberculosis all the plagues since the
beginning of time
we have survived alright we're gonna be
fine
just everybody pull in the same
direction if the government the leaders
tell you to do something just [ __ ] do
it if everybody does what they say this
thing will be over sooner rather than
later do yourself a huge favor take
advantage of the time to hang out with
your loved ones stay off of social media
unless you're watching some silly [ __ ]
like fails fail videos or whatever and I
would not watch the news there's no
reason to watch the news all they're
gonna do is freak you out cuz that is
the business that they are in alright in
my business is not to lead you it's just
to make you laugh that is it
I love the flat earther stuff anybody
got some good corned beef recipes let's
[ __ ] help each other out wait let's
say we have a good time during this
pandemic all right let's say it only
lasts two [ __ ] weeks I'm gonna tell
you this right now most people hate
their [ __ ] job you should take
advantage of the fact if you can stop
freaking out you should take advantage
of the fact that you don't have to
[ __ ] go to work today
huh you don't have to smell your boss's
bad [ __ ] breath as he tells you you
got to work another [ __ ] Saturday you
know god I wish I knew how to [ __ ] do
this
what's this while I did yeah so wouldn't
yank my big head down to the ground no I
think that what this is this is a great
practice for something even worse and
one of the worst things you can do in a
situation like this I think is not
listen to the people leading you and
also act as a [ __ ] individual there's
got to be that behavior but try to limit
it limit it try not to [ __ ] give in
to that [ __ ] when the herd starts
running though I'm telling you don't
watch Fox News don't watch CNN just
don't watch that [ __ ] alright don't
watch it just [ __ ] I don't know well
bill if we don't watch it how do we know
what the government's telling us to do
good point I don't know I don't know
where you go but just know that you just
watching people who are trying to
[ __ ] freak people out alright
everybody's gonna be alright some people
are gonna [ __ ] die
but not as many people who die every
year from a bunch of other [ __ ] alright
that's it okay I think we're gonna be
okay but then again I'm not a leader
okay so I don't know what to tell you
but by the way how great is it gonna be
when sports come back how [ __ ] great
how great is it gonna be to go out to go
see live music this is good it's a good
thing you're gonna have this
appreciation you know you like me we're
eating every [ __ ] morsel of what you
cooked huh sipping out that last little
bit of liquid
you know seeing how wasteful you've been
I went to reach for a paper towels like
you know I can wipe that out with a
[ __ ] rag it's actually very good for
the environment
not as many planes are flying a little
bit of fresh air and a lot of positive
things environmentally can come out of
this alright so that's it you know what
I usually say go [ __ ] yourself I'm not
gonna say that you know what I will say
that so I don't cause a panic why isn't
he saying go [ __ ] yourself go [ __ ]
yourselves I'll check in on you on
Thursday
enjoy your days off god bless